the intention of this talk was to give
people the opportunity to see kind of a
brief overview of all of the tools and
how they fit together one thing that
we've wanted to do at Pied at events for
a while there's a lot of things we want
to do a pied-à-terre events for some
time one of them is every time a new
version of some project comes out we'd
like to have any people in attendance
who might be working on that project to
give a short talk you know who needs to
hear sixty minutes of talk about new
color maps and matplotlib but maybe a
ten minute talk with a series of those
in a row outlining all the new features
and all the data science projects I
think that's something that we've done
in the past that we want to keep doing
more of one thing that I think we'd like
to do is for a lot of people at these
events not all of them are people who
are in the mud who are using these tools
every single day some of the people are
our events are scientists who really
only adopt a tool when they realize that
it's useful for their direct work and
maybe only when they run into some other
tool that needs this this package or if
they're making use of somebody else's or
if they're if they're referring to
somebody else's research it happens to
use a tool or if they have some
undergraduates some undergraduates or
graduate research assistants who have
decided to make use of some tool it's
not the same strongly guided process
that a software engineer would go
through to decide what tools they use
for a lot of scientists it really is
they focus on the work that they want to
do and then they kind of pick which
pieces and so as a result there's
oftentimes not a lot of knowledge about
how all the different tools put together
or what even all the tools are you'll
see there are a lot of people who you
know are using numpy who probably should
be using dined or pandas or even there's
actually one project that's not pi table
to say that one week ends with an X
x-ray x-ray x-ray x-ray slash x-ray
there's a lot of people who may not be
familiar with all the tools that are out
there there are people who should be
using PI tables who maybe aren't using
PI tables and so the thought was maybe
at some of our events to allocate a
little bit of time in order to just go
over that also one thing we want to do
is
I did event SAR predominantly or the
attendees of heightened events are
predominantly working professional data
scientists researchers and scientists in
academia and one thing is it's very
difficult for some of you to bring your
managers to these events to bring people
in leadership positions to say hey would
you like to spend a weekend with me
learning about the nitty-gritty details
of this technology and yet those people
make very important decisions that
affect how you use these tools in your
organization and so one thing that we'd
like to do is find better ways to reach
out to that audience but without
sacrificing the density of technical
content that PI data is known for so
just very recently I was talking to lea
about possible keynote speakers for an
upcoming event and it was actually in
reference to one area that's of a lot of
interest this year which is a polling
website so all these different web sites
that aggregate polls and do
meta-analysis of polls and there's a lot
of those out there one of them is owned
by ESPN one of them is run by the
University Princeton and I said you know
there's it would be great to have either
the people who run AI those websites
come speaking of high data event but if
you think about it the feeling for pi
data is more of let's get the person
who's at the academic institution who
has you know a very strong quantitative
background very rigorous background
who's focusing on this in terms of the
nitty-gritty details and we'll talk
about some of the science behind it over
maybe just somebody who is gonna give a
very fluffy talk about you know this
candidate is great or this Kent this
candidate's huge or this candidates
maybe not so great this can't always
it's sad this can it's sad or other
terms that are used to refer to the two
Kennedys so that's one thing that we'd
like to do we'd like to engage people in
these positions but engage them with a
lot of substance and to not just gloss
over the details but to give them a very
substantial and very credible
understanding of how the - what the
tools are and how they fit together and
so this is the first attempt of it now
given that this is the first attempt and
we have a fairly small audience here I
will probably depart a little bit from
the materials that I put together then
Kiros I put together just kind of just a
very brief overview of all the tools
that you see on the banner back here and
instead I'd like to inject a little bit
more tutorial content into this to talk
about what the projects are how the
projects work how something becomes an
unfocused project what it means for
something to be an unfocused project
what it means to contribute to them
focus and pie data and show you some
ways that you can become a part of that
process because one thing that's very
important and one thing that really
became very clear in an email I had to
send recently we are reaching out for
keynote speakers for upcoming events and
I had to explain to people who had never
heard about pie data or even really
attended a Python conference or even
maybe even a technical conference what
this is all about and I thought well
from their perspective what are they
thinking they're thinking of pie data in
reference to other large vendor
conferences run in industry and I
thought well one very important part of
this is I need to stress that this is a
member driven community this is a
community that's driven by volunteer
effort it's not a big vendor conference
we're not just doing pitches or demos of
products we're talking about open source
code we're talking about code that
everybody in this audience could
contribute to or could use if they chose
where it's it's a very different feel
and so that's one of the directions that
we need to take this talk and that we
need to take them focus and Paideia in
general to figure out how to make it as
participatory as possible and to really
let you know that I might be here in
front of the lectern it's not a podium
because it doesn't can't stand on it but
in front of the lectern but that doesn't
mean that there's a much of a distance
between the two of us it's why in fact I
like rooms like this and I like
audiences and crowds like this because
my goal here is to just talk about open
source why we do it why we volunteer
where that volunteer effort goes and
really motivate as many of you as much
as possible to get involved so I'll show
you some of the materials as with all of
my talks just because we're being
videoed I do like to start off and just
say this is an overview of the num focus
stack I'm James Powell this is PI data
San Francisco it's right
August 12 2016 so I'll start off very
simple who here knows what num focuses
who here has no clue it not focuses
honestly like some so the rest of you
are somewhere in the middle in some
state of both knowing and not knowing
that probably counts as not knowing now
notice when I asked who doesn't know
what them says liya here only
half-heartedly raised her hands when
sorry when I asked if they knew what
numb focuses and she works there so even
she doesn't really know what numb focus
is all about that joke that's a joke so
the easy answer to this instead enough
focused on work but I want to tell you
and I would likely if she could help
just speak about numb focus briefly but
numb focus is a first and foremost it's
a non-profit it's a 501c3 it's a
nonprofit in the United States where we
have pending EU status there's a
nonprofit that was founded I want to say
four or five years ago by by the two
thousand twelve so four years ago by
some of the people behind some of the
cordon focused projects and people
behind what used to be called ipython
there's now called project Jupiter the
people behind numpy be behind matplotlib
and the people behind Astro PI so the
developers of these projects the leaders
of these projects got together and
thought you know we need to have
something that's greater than the sum of
our parts we need to have a nonprofit
organization whose purpose is to promote
what we're doing to advance the cause of
open-source in data science in
scientific computing in numeric
computing and to help us do things like
build community and as a very practical
manner to help us in the process of
raising money very recently a project
joined um focus its toward the bottom of
this banner here it's called quant econ
I'll tell you very briefly later on what
Kuantan con is but suffice to say one of
the motivating forces for quant econ to
join them focus I'll also tell you what
it means to join them focus because they
wanted to raise money they wanted to go
to one of these large grant grant giving
institutions and say you know we want to
raise money in order to find
postdocs and the fun work on this
project and this project is not
commercial so there's no revenue here we
need we need donations and that
institution said you know it's very
important that you're part of a 501c3
not just administrative lean not just
legally but there's some meaning behind
that and they came back and told us
after they successfully raised a very
large amount of money that one of the
core reasons why their proposal was
accepted was that they were not just
part of a foundation like no focus but
they were part of Numb focus and that
there was a very strong thread tying
together all of the projects that the
people reviewing that grant proposal saw
that there was more to non focused than
just this legal entity there was a
mission behind it and there was the
ability for these different projects to
collaborate to improve the general
situation of open source in scientific
computing and data science you think
that's an accurate assessment Lia so the
focus is a 501 C 3 then focus happens to
be the organization that runs a PI data
conferences and I'll put a before we
move into the excited I'll put a little
asterisks next to that PI data
conferences like the conference that
you're at right now are not strictly run
by them focus they're run by
on-the-ground organizers and volunteers
they're run by you they're run by people
who are motivated to be part of and
build a community and those people say
there's a lot of interest in data
science we want to build a community
here we don't want that community to be
beholden to any one corporate interest
we want to do that out in the open
transparent we want it to be we want
everybody B to be welcome to participate
in this and we want to do it in such a
way as it supports the tools themselves
they come to num focus and say we run a
run an event recently we've gotten
emails about potentially a PI data event
in Philadelphia pi data events in st.
Petersburg and Moscow a PI D an event in
Columbia and in each of these cases it's
not us going to those places and
creating an event it's them come
to us and say we want to we want to be
part of something bigger they engage in
I'm focused and I'm focused as well
there's a lot of mechanics there's a lot
of operational logistical details to
running a conference I mean there's
catering there's t-shirts as all that
and I'm focus is willing to take upon a
lot of the administrative work you
wouldn't believe how much invoicing
there is for just a small conference
additionally none focus is interested in
making sure that all of the events
follow in a set of guiding principles
and these guiding principles haven't
been enumerated but I can rip a couple
of those for you one of them is that we
want to make sure that every talk is
about open source we want to make sure
that there's no vendor talks there's
nobody coming here trying to sell you
something I always like to say one
little caveat to that which is we've
done events at Microsoft in the past we
will do an event on Microsoft next year
there will be a speaker today speaking
or sorry a speaker tomorrow speaking
about Windows and in that one case you
could think you could see a talk about
Windows but you can't use anything in
that talk unless you pay money for
Windows but I feel that there's a
there's an extenuating circumstance
there and that Windows is just such a
big thing but other than that we don't
want speakers to come and say oh here's
something great that I built now pay me
money before you can use it that's not
in the spirit of open source it's not in
the spirit of community these talks are
not supposed to pitch you in the sense
of convince you to buy something but
they can pitch you in the sense of
convincing you to buy into an idea or to
buy into an approach but there shouldn't
be there should be non-commercial in
nature that's one of the guiding
principles another one is when we look
at the schedules of these events and we
help we help put together the schedule
and help with the collection of
proposals and help with the with the
proposal selection committees I actually
sit on those proposal selection
committees and they're typically run by
the on-the-ground organizers in the
sense that they're the ones who are
saying I like this talk I don't like
this talk I think this talk would be
better if it's a tutorial I think this
talk would be better if they covered
more of this material I've seen this
speaker before it was great things like
that those are the decisions they make
the reason I sit on those is to make
sure that for example when they go
through all the talks will you do
another pass and we say well listen are
we representing all the different areas
equally are we broadly representing all
of our community equally it's a very
important thing to numb
focus are we making sure that we don't
have the same speakers giving talks over
and over and over again and we're making
it difficult for new speakers to come up
and give their very first talk and so
those are some of the core principles
that we focus on so numb focus has that
responsibility in providing some overall
governance to pie data it's also the
role that them focus has with regard to
the projects themselves so let me tell
you let's talk about what an unfocused
projects are because that's what the
topic of this tutorial session was
supposed to be there are two links on
the num focus website with the projects
I'm going to open them both up and we'll
just briefly take a look and you can see
that you can see all of them represented
on the banner behind me
and under this affiliated project list
you can see some which are not on the
banner behind me and you can see some
which you might recognize scikit-learn
of course and some what you might spider
even some what you might not recognize
the aforementioned xra orange actually I
don't know I still don't know what
oranges some which you might not might
have seen in a long time
pylab Python XY is here and you can see
that this hasn't quite been updated
because we have a couple of projects to
be added to this if she's able to I'd
like to invite Leah to speak about some
of the new projects that are in the
process of applying for sponsorship from
not focus so Phoenix is one that's
already gotten through the process
there's a couple others that are in the
pipeline but that's up to the F she want
to discuss in what you can see is
there's a difference between sponsors
and affiliated projects and this is one
reason why I really wanted Leah to be
part of this this tutorial session so we
could speak very specifically about that
think about this all of you have some
code that you've written that you'd like
to put out into the road and you'd like
to put on github and you'd like to make
into something more than just what yet
another repository that people start
that you refer to on your resume when
you're applying for your next job maybe
you have something that you've been
working on for a very long time
and you really want to see it thrive and
maybe you even have already gotten a lot
of interest from people submitting bug
bug reports submitting patches helping
you with this project but you want to
turn it into something
more than just a bunch of people on
github approving pull requests you might
even want to raise money for that you
might say well listen we all are very
busy on our day jobs and one of us is
you know one job change away from not
being able to manage this project
anymore so we need to make sure this
project is sustainable we need to make
sure that this tool which we put all
this effort into is still maintained
five or ten years from now how often
have you gotten really excited about
something that you saw on github you're
like this is gonna solve all of my
problems then you look on the right
column when the last commit was and
you're like this hasn't been updated for
three years there's no way this is gonna
work this is a very serious problem for
a lot of projects and I can tell you in
my own experience I've seen a lot of
projects where I was really excited from
the description of what it does and then
I try and use it oh it's not compatible
with the version of Python that I'm
using oh there's no Python 3 version for
it oh you know that some API behind the
scenes has changed and I don't really
want to dig into that project to work
out all those details and the project
maintainer has moved on to other things
and I can't complain that they've moved
on to other things that's a volunteer
effort but you can see that these
projects are not sustainable it would be
very it would have a very big impact on
all of our lives if that happened to any
of these projects and that's one of the
goals of them focused to make sure that
all of these projects are sustainable
that if you go to somebody in your
company and say we're gonna build
something or we build something big it's
our last for 10 years we're gonna build
it on numpy and build it on Python numpy
using the notebook they have some
assurance that that code will still run
a ten years time it'll still be
supported think about if you're a
researcher and you're producing research
today and that research could go make
policy decisions could affect policy
decisions people are going to need to
revisit that research in five or ten
years time when they start to see the
effects of that policy that code needs
to be reproducible it needs to still run
in order for that code to still run
there need to be people who are actively
maintaining that code base who
understand who understand what has
changed that code base from when you
first learn your analysis to now who are
able to give you guidance in terms of
how to rerun old code
and you would be I once tried an
exercise I spent an entire weekend on
this I thought what happens if it's the
end of the world and I'm left with just
the computer and I need to rerun all the
code I need to rebuild civilization but
not but not in the biblical sense in the
sense of rebuilding all the code that
has been lost because of some a
population situation so I thought okay I
can build the tools that I use in a data
science stack from source I can download
the source code for Jupiter and I can
build the pieces that are not pure
Python I can do the same thing for most
of maybe numpy inside pie some of the
Fortran stuff is a little bit hard to
build but I can build a lot of that from
source and I can build Python from
source so I don't really need if
anaconda falls off the face of the earth
it would really negatively affect my
life but I could struggle and make
things work so my question is well
that's great but can I build my compiler
so I started to try to build my compiler
I thought can i boost rap this could i
sitting at it at a desk with a computer
that had nothing on it build a really
small compiler that could build a bigger
compiler that could build a bigger
compiler that could build GCC that could
build python that could build the data
science stack and you could think that
it's not it might not be
it is a far-fetched scenario so it may
not be the most realistic scenario but
it is worthwhile to think about if
you're really concerned about
reproducible research so I tried this I
can't build GCC more than three years
back on on my machine at all I can't
build a older GCC with a newer GCC I
can't start with the oldest GCC and
build a GCC I can't start with a non GCC
compiler and build in GCC it's pretty
much nothing I could do other than maybe
get old ISO s run them in a virtual
machine and build things it's actually
quite surprising how brittle some of the
foundational software that we rely upon
is and think about I couldn't even start
to build those tools because of
fundamental changes in the compilers
themselves much less build GCC and all
of the libraries that they depend on the
hundreds of libraries they depend on
I mean think about it a few if you
suddenly had to bootstrap or working
Linux install it wouldn't be possible
without the continuity of sustainability
there without the continuity development
that we take for granted so that said
the core question was the difference we
two sponsored an affiliated project so
you've already bought into the value of
sustainability you've already bought
into the value of having somebody who
can help you with issues of governance
help you decide the direction of that
project sponsor and affiliated projects
are one of the core distinctions between
the projects behind them focus
affiliated projects or projects for whom
the focus has helped by raising money or
by giving grants sponsored projects are
really the core of what we talk about
when we talk about the non focused
projects there's actually two separate
types of sponsored projects there's the
grantor grantee and the comprehensive
sponsored projects Lea can actually tell
you which of these projects are under
which model but essentially in the
comprehensive model oops in the
comprehensive model the intellectual
property for that project is signed over
to num focus and num focus manages that
project num focus is the organization
who owns intellectual property that
project it manages it very much in the
same way that the PSF owns the
intellectual property for the python
language and handles high-level issues
around that the reason for that can be
as as small as I have a project and I
have some of my co-workers who work at
some company who work on this project
and I want this to be an open source
project we hear the word open source
bandied about all the time and it means
many different things typically it means
nothing more than the source code exists
somewhere not even under version control
not even the most recent source code not
even the history of all the source code
but some copy of the running source code
exists somewhere and that's all that it
means for open source and so you can see
a lot of people who talk about their
open source research well it's open
source in the sense that there's some
directory with some version of the code
that may or may not work that may not be
the version that they actually used in
the paper that's available and you can
think of there are gradations of
that meaning of open source you can
think that a lot of companies like to
talk about their commitment to open
source and what that means is they have
a github page under their company name
and they released some version of the
code on github and that's about it and
if you say well there's a bug here
here's a pull request
maybe they respond maybe they don't if
you say I don't like the direction this
project is going who can I talk to
because I think it needs to go this
direction or I want to contribute to
that they probably will not respond the
actual management of the project is done
internally at the company it's just the
artifacts of that the source code itself
are available to the world to see and
you can think that that's you know it's
better than getting a binary because you
can't really do much with the binary but
it's only a slight translation it's just
the artifact that existed before the
construction in the binary but otherwise
the actual benefits of it being open
source are missing in num focus is view
open source should mean much more than
that now there is a humongous debate
between what it means for something to
be free versus open source and that's
something I don't think I want to get
into if you've if you read hacker news
there was a debate about that very
recently with a lot of contentious
comments but I want to talk a little bit
higher level a little bit more broadly
about what open sources consider that a
software project where all the
contributors and all the developers and
all the people leading that project work
at a single company it's open source and
they should be lauded for that project
being open source but it's not a
community project it's not a project
that anybody off the street can
contribute to without having to jump
through certain groups certainly any
company is more than happy to take bug
reports or bug fixes from people if they
don't have to pay for it but does that
mean that they're willing to entertain
discussions publicly about the direction
of the project does that mean they're
willing to tell people this is where the
project is going in six months time or a
month time there's no guarantee of that
at all a community project an
open-source project is a project where
the community is the organization that
that pushes for that project where if
you want to make changes to that project
there's at least a stated way to make
change that
a governance document that says this is
the steering committee that makes these
decisions here's transparency in terms
of how the decisions are made this
project is not has anyone used an open
source project that then became closed
source I used one that I won't name that
was closed source became open source
then became closed sourced again then
the company ran out of business then
became open source and you could think
that if if this is part of some
corporate IP then there's severe
restrictions about the use of that tool
as well or whether that tool will stay
open source a community project is a
project where we know that it's open
source today will be open source
tomorrow the open source the next day
there's some guarantee that the
governance of this project is in the
hands of the community that by virtue of
being part of a non-profit they're free
from certain commercial influences that
I don't want to ascribe malevolence to
it but there are certain commercial
influences where if you have a start-up
and you produce a lot of open source
code and the startup folds you may be
under certain restrictions as to who
owns that code or whether that code can
still stay in the wild that are outside
of your control
and it's unfortunate but it happens and
it happens actually fairly often which
is often why you'll see startups where
you can't figure out their funding model
a lot of the code is open source because
the people who work unlike if this thing
falls over I least want to be able to
use the code that I wrote for the last
five years that said in the grants or
grantee so that's that's open source
from a view of a comprehensive model now
I'm not actually sure of all of the
projects and where they fit under the
grants or grantee versus comprehensive
split I know that the actual split from
them focused projects is a little bit
more nuanced than just those two
categories but in my understanding the
grantor grantee is more of a legal
relationship where the project already
has its own internal mechanisms that
they manage for governance of the
project and then focus serves more of a
legal purpose than this community
purpose would you say that's accurate
the manimals fire grenades will happen
on the Richter prettiest or you're
pre-approved for grant which focus can
can get a grand or higher grant every
cuts through its greatness to that
project it's all three so you can see
that now the purpose of this talk was to
go through the projects and to give you
a very brief overview of how they fit
together and what they are so I would
say the very beginning of this is we can
we can actually go to the sponsored
project and the affiliated project pages
but I think in my view there is actually
quite a few different graphics that
people have for how they look at these
and the graphics are uniformly pretty
terrible I'll show you two of them two
of them pulled from other presentations
but here's one I mean this isn't this
isn't so bad
scientific ecosystem where you can see
there are kind of bands or orbits of
different projects and here's another
one that's just pretty horrible because
I don't know why scythe on sits on top
of side pipe and as a MATLAB so I have
no idea how these are supposed to be
orientated but I would say that you can
think probably the most visible project
project that you use is going to be
Jupiter notebook Jupiter notebook and
ipython so the notebook in which I built
those slides and a notebook that we're
all familiar with the one that we all
love written by or these project led by
Fernando Perez and Brian Grainger is an
unfocused project it's actual
one of the first projects when was
Jupiter who joined them focus or ipython
was ipython so this is actually before
the introduction of the Jupiter brand by
the way Brian Granger will be here
tomorrow speaking about his next project
Altair visualization library which is
still too early in the process to
consider you know something like fiscal
sponsorship but Leah I've seen has
already started bugging him and asking
him why isn't this an unfocused project
because the reason is when you weave a
rich tapestry of projects it makes each
of the projects better and I want to
talk to you about I want to make sure
that I speak about that before the
endless because there's something that
num focus is doing this year that has
that they've not done in the last four
years that really speaks to the reason
to have this coalition of align projects
before I go into the Python side I'd
like to say that PI data has a
reputation for being a Python conference
pi is in the name and a lot of the
original projects Astro PI matplotlib
ipython who all Python numpy were all
Python projects then I'm focused
sometimes has a reputation of being
focused just on Python that's not true
then focus was founded to support open
source scientific software irrespective
of what language it is so while you're
in your Jupiter notebook starting at the
very beginning you might want to use the
Giulia language and it turns out that
the Giulia language is also an unfocused
fiscally sponsored project so if any of
you out there are planning to use Giulia
language it's a fantastic tool it's a
nice replacement for our in fact if you
would like to learn more about the
Giulia language there is a fantastic
tutorial which room are you in
we're gonna be in this room right after
this session right after this session
giving a tutorial about Juliet so I
won't actually speak about it that much
more but I'll tell you it's a great
replacement for our in my humble opinion
I would not use it as a replacement for
Python just because it's more of a
analytical or scientific tool than a
systems tool so I wouldn't I wouldn't
I wouldn't write up I would use it as
the core of my analysis surrounded by
some pieces that are for operational use
I don't know if that's an unfair
assessment or not it is however a very
very exciting project and I hope in
Toni's demos I'll show you some of the
exciting demos of just a very easy to
write generic code that runs faster than
you could believe additionally if you
think about open source scientific tools
there's Python which we'll get to is
Julia and there is our numbers a
fiscally sponsor's a project in the our
ecosystem called our open side now our
open side is a little bit hard to pin
down in terms of what it is if I want to
describe to you what our open science I
would say for a Python programmer our
open side is the equivalent of it sits
somewhere halfway between something like
something like pi PI and something like
psy pi it's a collection of packages for
scientific computing written by the are
open SCI contributors and also written
by members of the community that are
made available via our open side one of
our open size focuses is reproducibility
in computing and when you look at let me
see if I can show you the packages and
when you look at this topic of
reproducibility and research and
reproducible computing this is another
common thread that you see throughout
the non focused projects one thing about
Jupiter notebook is Jupiter notebook
isn't just about having slick web-based
environments it is about being able to
bridge the gap between what you publish
in your research or what you deliver in
your research and the actual code that
you run so that it's not the case that
we all remember a couple years back
economic analysis where they had hidden
a couple of rows and the analysis turned
out to be incorrect when we short when
we when we shorten that gap between the
two we can avoid those kind of issues
so our open sigh is kind of a collection
of packages for the our language for a
variety of different scientific
tasks additionally before I dive into
Python there are a couple of other
things that are part of num focused or
aren't exactly software projects two of
I think the most exciting new num focus
projects that join in the last I want to
say two years two or three years are
data carpentry and software carpentry we
have a one of the board members for num
focus and one and the leader of data
carpentry coming tomorrow to speak to
Tracy teal to be keynoting in the
morning data carpentry and software
carpentry our initiatives their
educational initiatives where we've all
seen scientific code we've all seen the
quality of code written by scientists
but it's not their fault it's not their
priority and it's not their background
and there's a lot of value that can be
brought by helping researchers
understand how to use software better
and not just understanding and there's
one thing I think is very critical it's
not just understanding how to program
better it's not just learning about
async i/o and Python 35 or learning
about you know multiple dispatch in
Julia it's also about the software
development process a lot of people
working in scientific research or people
or even data scientists are still too
far from what you might consider as good
practice and software development and
I'll give you an example and I and I
hate to harp on the art community but
the art community is a lot of
statisticians who don't come from a
software developer background so I was
seeing a talk i saw a talk last year at
an our conference and the speaker was
like reproducibility loop reducible
computing is really important so what I
do is whenever I put something up on
github I create a readme file with all
the packages that it needs I was like
that's the level of reproducibility that
you've reached there's no thought of I
mean think about all the various
approaches for packaging in the Python
ecosystem and for being able to
deterministically reproduce computing
environments and then for some for some
environments for statisticians you know
they're at the stage of just saying oh
remember to install these three
don't worry about the version number
that's apparently not that important or
don't worry about the exact code that's
running that's not that important or you
know container rising it so it's
actually reproducible you know they're
still lagging behind and I don't want
I'm gonna say that's not a criticism of
them it's just that for a statistician
their focus is not doesn't doesn't go
far beyond the statistics they want to
do and so there's a lot of information
about good practice and software
development that they need to that they
know they need to do better that they
know they need to improve on but they
just don't have the resources for them
and that's the purpose of initiatives
like software carpentry and data
carpentry to be able to bring that to
researchers to be able to tell them you
know there's a reason that version
control is something that no program no
software developer would live without
and here are the advantages of it and
here's how you can integrate it into
your workflow without having to pay all
that cost of enormous amounts of
overhead and setup it's not just some
kind of self-indulgent gratuitous
application of soft development process
there's actual real benefits from this
and here's how you can employ those
benefits without having to necessarily
go down the rabbit hole of incredibly
logistical II complex deployment
workflows additionally there's one more
there's one more num focus project that
kind of sits in the middle quant econ
Kwon econ started as an educational
project Tom Sargent 2011 Nobel Prize
winner in economics had a mission to
improve the improve the quality of
discourse in economics especially with
regards to computational methods and
numerical methods and so quant econ
started as a collection of essentially
notebooks and Jupiter and sorry in
Jupiter notebooks in Python and Julia
just teaching topics in econometrics and
in a continent and in economics since
becoming a nun focus fiscally sponsored
project quant econ has decided to
actually take a lot of the common code
that they've seen in a lot of these
projects and look towards building tools
look towards building libraries look
towards
simplify you know building an equivalent
of something like Astro PI but for
economists at least that's my
understanding of so in addition to that
so the rest of these are basically
Python projects and I wanted to show you
kind of how they fit together
Oh Stan is not a Python project but has
Python bindings so this was can I tell
them the story of Stan it's all it's all
true so Stan was Stan was I mean it's
all out there so Stan was like we should
say this but stamp Stan was one of these
things where I went to juliek on two
years ago and I talked about num focus
of Julia Khan and somebody came up to me
from a certain project who I won't name
and they were like you know when I go to
my University and I get a grant they
take sixty cents for every dollar that I
get and that's an absurd amount of money
that's not going to the project that's
going to administrate a costs and I said
you know num focus takes less than 15%
of that they were like you know maybe we
should become an unfocused project that
is one of the driving forces from an
unfocused project and that as an
organization that is outside of you know
the very large bureaucracies of the
university system they're able to put a
lot more of the money that's brought
into the project directly to actually
supporting the project and kind of trim
I mean you can see kind of a bare-bones
operation here but trim trim some of the
fat right stan is a project coming out
of Columbia coming out of Andy
gell-mann's research group it's a
statistical modeling tool Stan kind of
stan has its own DSL for for defining
statistical models and then they
compiled their they wrote a C++ library
to take that DSL parse it and compile it
and then provide analysis giving your
model it's a very powerful tool it is it
has bindings for R and Python and so
most likely most of you will be using
stand via its binding spy Stan I don't
think we've had anybody at any pilot
events come speak about PI Stan but I
think that's something that would be
very valuable because it's a it's a very
powerful and very
useful tool so I think those are I think
the rest of our tools are all Python
tools so let's start with let's start
with the sticker game so after lunch or
actually the afternoon today we'll have
all the stickers out of the non focus
booth and the reason that I decided to
put together this tutorial was in part
when we have all the stickers laid out
at the booth
people want to take stickers they don't
always know what the stickers are and
they ask what's that the sticker for and
so it puts us on the spot to be able to
say oh that's a sticker for such and
such and then they of course you're
gonna ask well what is what does that do
so you have to learn what all the
projects do even if you don't use them
there are a couple of these projects
that I can't go into a lot of depth in
terms of what they do just because they
are far outside of my area of expertise
in fact I'll tell you which of those
there are I don't really know a lot
about Jensen or there's or psychic bio
they're just too far outside of what I
do in terms of my work I can tell you
very briefly what they are but I can't
tell you some of them any great details
so with the sticker game I'll tell you
the stickers which people have the
hardest time recognizing them so the
first one that people have a really hard
time recognizing is a numpy sticker
except once you tell them it's a numpy
sticker they kind of understand what the
logo is supposed to be about and
everybody knows with vampires
it's a library and python for n
dimensional arrays and computations on
them and so now you can kind of
understand what it is it's an N
dimensional array so the sticker is see
it's a three-dimensional array and so of
course that's that matplotlib of course
we're all familiar with matplotlib many
of one thing that you might not know
matplotlib I feel that something is is a
tool very similar to Bosch and SQL in
the sense that most people who learn
matplotlib learn it from tutorials that
were written 5 or 10 years ago
and completely failed to recognize that
these are actively developed so when was
the last time you met somebody like I
know SQL except they learn SQL like
around SQL 92 about 14 years ago and
you're like we know this actually is
there's actually a very recent SQL
standard it has a lot of really neat
features or somebody who's writing bash
as though over 1996 like we in a bash
for came out about 10 years ago
a lot of neat features a lot of the
stuff that you're doing a bash you don't
have to do anymore
same thing with matplotlib mad pot lips
not ugly anymore it used to be pretty
pretty rough to look at but now it's
pretty nice to look at and they've put a
lot of effort into improving the just a
visual appeal of the graphs it's
actually a very actively maintained
project and it's something where you
need a lot of value out of keeping up to
date what changes in matplotlib even
though it's been around for so long when
you look at a lot of reference material
look at a book or look at some tutorials
online you're bound to run at things
which are maybe five or ten years or or
written five or ten or 15 years ago 5 or
10 years ago I'd say another one that
people don't recognize unless it has the
name of the project nor it sympa the
snake and the cube sin pi is a computer
algebra system it's basically a symbolic
mathematics system we it's a project
that's been around for a very long time
I would say if you want to compare it to
something that you might be more
familiar with it's a subset of a much
smaller subset of some of the
functionality that people are originally
drawn to when they want to use a tool
like Mathematica so being able to do
symbolic algebra being able to do
symbolic differentiation integration
being able to do math in Python that's
not just numerical approaches that's
actual math the next project that we'll
talk about is Astro Phi and as Leah said
Astro pie was one of the founding
projects for num focus it was one of the
first projects that joined it's
essentially a tool for just astronomers
for Australian calculations you can do
things like you can you can predict
where the stars are going to be in star
maps and things like that it is one of
these tools that's a little bit outside
of my area of expertise just because I
don't do any astronomy work but you can
understand from the name that even if
the logo isn't as clear we should
probably at some point figure out what
the logo is supposed to represent
there's one other example of a tool
whose logo we we don't quite know what
it is although I had some thoughts
yt everybody wants to know YT
because the name isn't that descriptive
so YT is a tool for volumetric data
geospatial data and so when I heard
geospatial data and I looked at I looked
at the image I thought is that a
topological graph but apparently this is
something it's used in astronomy as well
and so apparently this is some
astronomical figure so it's a case of
having a sticker and logo that's not
quite as obvious as you might think
pi tables pi tables is a project that's
been around for a very long time that
there's a lot of really fancy things but
just doesn't seem to get that much
marketing a lot of a lot of the time you
have enormous amounts of data that you
don't want to that you don't have the
ability to load into memory all at once
that you want to do analysis on most
likely you're going to reach for a tool
like hdf5 for in order to store this
data pi tables is a very convenient
wrapper over on disk data for giving you
something akin to pandas like
manipulation of that data I've used it
it's a very simple tool but uh but it's
a very helpful tool I used it when I had
financial data which was you know tick
level data that was far too large for me
to load into memory and a single Python
process at one point in time but I had
so much and only just look at a small
subset of it need to filter through it
and pull out certain certain parts of
that signal pi tables is that closely is
developed by some people who are closely
associated with another project that's
not an unfocused project it's much lower
level than all of these WASC I would
really suggest if you're interested in
incredibly large datasets and how to
manipulate them Blas was a very
interesting project it's a compression
library at PI data Berlin 2013 there was
a talk about blossom wife Francesca Ted
where he had some really nice demos
where he showed that in some cases
memory bandwidth was so small but
processing power was so great he could
compress data he could pretty good he
could compress data that he would be
that the compressed data coming that he
was loading into memory or let me see if
I remember the exact
Tito's he was doing operations on
compressed data or unused sorry he was
loading data in compressed form into
memory performing operations on it and
then compressing it back and was faster
than running on the the uncompressed
data itself III don't think that I've
relayed his results too precisely but I
would suggest that you look at that and
so that's an overview of all of the
projects here of course ipython is an
unfocused supporter project separate
from Jupiter as you know there's been a
forking between these two or Jupiter
refers to tools like the notebook that
are used in Giulia Python and our
ipython exists as not only a kernel but
still it's still an actively maintained
Python interactive console replacement
and so for those of you who need to drop
down into a Python interactive console
ipython is still actively maintained it
has a really really nice multi-line
editing mode so you know everybody
always has some pain with ipython using
multi-line editing because you can't
scroll up or you can't change things
the recent ipython has really nice mode
for doing that so those are all of the
fiscally sponsored projects I want to
show you some of the affiliated projects
and then I want to open the floor for
some discussion and I also want to bring
Leah in just to talk about the future of
them focus and where we're all of you as
an audience fit into this you're going
to see a talk
I think it's today on bouquet which is a
plotting library for interactive
visualization bouquet is an affiliated
project it can I tell them about bouquet
bouquet is in the process of applying to
be an unfocused project if this is a
tool that you use please please please
come speak to Leah myself or Brian
vandeman because they're looking for
people to sit on the steering committee
for that project many of you when you do
visualization you might reach for a tool
like matplotlib and matplotlib is a
fantastic tool for what you might
consider to be publication quality
graphics so if you're producing
visualizations that are going to be
published they're part of some paper map
matplotlib gives you an
a very fine-grained ability to control
the the specific details of how that is
represented in in published form on
paper matplotlib is a little bit weaker
in the area of interactive graphics okay
is aiming very directly at interactive
visualizations so the demos that you'll
see in the bouquet tutorial are all
about here's how we have a graphic and
here's how we can interact with it
beyond things like just you know
highlighting points and zooming in but
also having very richly interactive
graphics you've all seen some of the
demos with ipython widgets in in the
Jupiter notebook and one thing that
people like about that is suddenly I
have some visualization I can kind of
pull a slider back and forth and see how
that value affects my computation but
it's slow because that's to redraw every
time and it's kind of clunky I would say
the quality of interactive
visualizations that you can put together
with okay or absolutely incredibly
impressive the other thing that bouquet
is focusing on is finding ways to
represent incredibly large incredibly
dense potentially streaming data sets so
there's one demo that Brian vandeman can
show you where he has I think Millions I
think he has 10 or 20 million data
points from the city of New York from
some kind of census data that he's
representing and he can zoom in and he
can represent it all at once and he can
zoom in and look at subsets of that do
different filtering of that data set
very impressive now one reason I want to
spend a little bit of extra time talking
about bouquet is bouquet was originally
a project that came out of a company
called continuum analytics continuum
analytics is the founding sponsor for PI
data and the founding sponsor for and
one of the founding sponsors for them
focus it is a for-profit company that
puts a lot of money and a lot of time
into developing open source tools
anaconda is a product from CATIA
magnetics that is also open source one
thing about bouquet and we've gotten a
lot of really positive feedback
a lot of support from the the business
leaders at continuum analytics is that
okay the main developers from okay our
continuum employees one thing that is a
restriction for an unfocused sponsored
project is the people on the steering
committee have to represent a variety of
different interests and that's kind of
the transition continuum has projects
that for one reason or another it
doesn't want to go through that the oh
there's a lot of red tape and a lot of
paperwork that needs to be done to make
it an unfocused project or maybe it's a
very small project or it's a project
that's very narrowly focused but still
open-source nevertheless bouquet is
reaching a point where there is a desire
to take it from being a a corporate
sponsored nonprofit into a community
sponsored sorry a corporate sponsored
open-source project into a community
sponsored open-source project another
similar project is tasks I don't think
we have a task talk at this event but
prior previous pipette events have
featured a lot of talks on tasks tasks
is a kind of parallel computing
framework you can think just building
computation graphs and abstracting where
the computations are actually performed
I psyched on I'm sure we're all familiar
with site on site on is a transpiler
from Python to see I I said in my
tutorial earlier today that very few
people in the audience had ever used
async i/o for anything and one of the
reasons for that is the push for async
i/o is usually a performance a desire
for a greater performance a desire to
eliminate issues with blocking i/o for
data scientists a lot of the limitation
that you have is you have CPU bound
problems not IO bound problems and most
likely the optimization strategy that
you'll take will be take my code use
number two see if I can gin it if that
doesn't work try and see if I can cite
denies it if that isn't work try and
write it as a C extension module or if
it's for something like a very large
data flow problem use something like
tasks and async IO just doesn't come up
that much
well scythe on is probably the very
first step for a lot of you in taking
code that's written in Python and seeing
if you can either integrate it into code
that's written in C or
or make use of some of the performance
benefits of writing C code without
actually having to suffer from some of
the limitations of the C language die nd
is a very interesting project that
doesn't get a lot of press when it first
came out a lot of people are talking
about it but it's a very specific and
very narrow tool Dianne D is a C++
library for an N dimensional array not
or for an N dimensional typed data it's
a much more general tool than how people
usually see it people often see Diane D
as or dimed as a next-generation numpy a
replacement for numpy but i would
encourage you to look at the tool a
little bit closer it's actually a lot
more general than just being an umpire
replacement number the aforementioned
number is a ginning framework for python
so using LVM and using some tools in
python namely or rather rather by
performing certain static analysis of
python code and using some of the tools
in LLVM taking Python code producing
versions of that Python code that can
identify hot paths and then get those
hot paths
so the original canonical example for
number was a function that calculated a
Mandelbrot fractal you could think
that's a very problem that has very
easily identifiable hot paths with very
little dynamic nature in terms of the
data types are there numbers are able to
identify those and get I think a
thousand times speed-up is what they
were showing in that original demo you
can think that the approaches here are
very similar to what people are trying
to do with pipe pipe I accept number as
a tool for C Python code orange is one
of the tools including Jemison that I
don't really know that much about Python
X Y I think a lot of you know Python X
YS pylab kind of a come a combination of
a variety of different tools that are
used in
scientific computing Sify of course is
one of the actually I'd say Syfy is what
these the people behind sci-fi wall so
some of the founding members of them
focus yeah so that's that's that's one
of them but Syfy as many of you already
know is a collection of tools in Python
for scientific computing
whereas numpy is really just the NDA and
things around the India right Syfy is
more of a grab bag of different things
for different areas in scientific
computing
so in Syfy you'll see things like
spatial subdivision algorithms right
next to statistical algorithms like you
know calculating kurtosis a scikit-learn
and the other psychic related projects
like an image in sci-fi oh I would say
that I can't imagine that this talk
would give those projects any more press
than they already have of course these
are your premier machine learning
libraries there has been a very strong
push to make scikit-learn a num focused
project and it's something that we hope
in the near future can happen the reason
for that is as you're beginning to see
the tapestry of all these projects
imagine you're using your jupiter
notebook to do machine learning you do
that machine learning what scikit-learn
scikit-learn itself uses numpy behind
the scenes you do some data analysis
with pandas which one of the tools i
forgot to mention on the fiscally
sponsored page you have some
visualization output you use matplotlib
you have all these tools working in
concert with each other and that's great
but you know why do we need them focus
well one of the things that we're trying
to do this year is hold an unfocused
summit a summit of summits this is going
to be held around PI data DC later this
year where we're going to get all of the
project leaders for all the time focused
projects together to help tear down some
obstacles to collaborate within the
projects so think how often does how
often is there unnecessary overlap
between what each of these tools do I
mean there's a lot of overlap between
what pandas does with regards to I mean
pandas ends up wrapping a lot of numpy a
lot of matplotlib think about rough
spots in that kind of wrapping think
about areas where all of these projects
could make use
some consensus around data formats tools
like arrow that West West McKinney has
been talking about recently and building
that consensus getting all the projects
on the same page and getting them to
collectively decide a direction to go
could unify development of these tools
and really accelerate their development
could also really help us eliminate some
of these uncomplete lis unnecessary
areas of friction in terms of how the
tools integrate with each other I mean
think about all the ways they think
about how many times you've used a tool
and you're like you know I wish Jupiter
notebook had a much more convenient way
to pretty print this output
I wish Jupiter notebook could represent
this data a little bit better or could
handle this type of exception a little
bit better there's a lot of work that
can be done there and it's difficult
where the tools themselves are somewhat
siloed for them to collaborate in that
fashion they all of the project
maintainer ZnO each other and they all
communicate with each other frequently
online but getting them all together in
one room for a couple of days really
makes a big difference and that's one
thing that num focus is going to do this
year and you can begin to see the power
of having all of these related tools
under that same umbrella so the last
four tools here piano piano I think is
typically thought of as a deep learning
library it's in the same way as dined a
little bit broader than that it's
supposed to be a library for you know
effective computation of
multi-dimensional arrays in addition to
things like being able to do derivation
on to be doing numerical derivation on
these so you can think for deep learning
you build you know very large structures
of or you represent the network as a
very large multi-dimensional array and
then you do things like figure out you
do your back propagation and forward
propagation stats models is a library
for statistical computations there's a
lot of overlap between what stats models
does and what certain parts of
scikit-learn do I would say stats models
is supposed to be a statistical tool for
statisticians and so oftentimes what I'm
doing things like corporate training and
I talked about scikit-learn and I talked
about stats models I
can show examples doing linear
regression in using tools coming out of
Sai by using stats models or using
scikit-learn and the reason that I often
choose to do the example using stats
models is that the output is very
similar to what an AR user would expect
what a statistician would look like so
there's a lot of focus on things like
you know metrics like r-squared and
whatnot whereas scikit-learn is more
about machine learning and and producing
predictions finally x-ray is a tool that
I don't know too much about x-ray is you
know one of the big limitations of numpy
Zandi array is that you have the you
don't have the ability to look at label
dimensions so you can think how many
people are using n dimensional data but
they want to have labels on that
dimension they want to have some kind of
pandas behavior but they're not looking
at tabular data they're looking at array
data but they need some of the slicing
and dicing and indexing ability that you
get with tabular data with pandas X
array is trying to be at pandas but for
scientists who are not looking at
tabular data we're not looking at
columnar data
lastly spider is an interactive
development environment for Python we
all we all have used tools like PyCharm
and we've used tools like maybe even
jupiter lab and spider is just a
development of Revit so with that said
that's the actual core content that I
wanted to just share with you just a
very brief overview of all the projects
just some terms you might hear some
names you might hear just a little bit
of information to guide you in the right
direction for this is something that
might be more interesting for me to look
into but also to give you a little bit
of context about where why these
projects are under than unfocused
spanner what num focus is all about
that's that so with that said you know
we have a lot of time I would love with
Leah could talk about some of the future
of them focus and we're now focus is
going where the tools are going and also
before we leave I would like to talk
about you know how do you fit into this
because the purpose of this talk and the
purpose of this event is not for you to
come and just see me talk about this
stuff I can speak for days about this
but it's not it's not that valuable
apart
here is to give you enough information
to motivate you or engage you to do
something with that either you know in a
BOF session that we might run tomorrow
or the next day to see are you
interested in helping out with PI data
are you interested in being a being on
the speaker selection committee are you
interested in being one of the
organizers somebody on the ground who's
helping us run these events part of a
committee that makes sure that these
events you know we've done a lot of
additional initiatives events like women
and Technology things if that's
something you interested in we want to
motivate you to volunteer from an
unfocused side it's a little bit harder
because you know this is mostly for
people who are working on open-source
projects but it's very likely that you
you may be working on a project like
this or you may know people are working
on a project like this you have certain
questions about well I've got
contributors I've got code where does it
go from here so that's one thing that
I'd like to talk about before we break
but I'd like to give some time for Leah
to tell me all the things that I said
walk
so where's numb focus going what are
there any new projects that are in the
pipeline that you want to talk about
other than bouquet are they too early in
the tweets it
most projects do you want the the
comprehensive model because they want to
be able to take advantage of the the
benefit of being able to totally release
their financial administration over so
so they can do what they do best and and
we can do what you know the help that we
can bring to to the projects
so that's I mean that's what we're what
no focus was created for and as as James
said the four the five founding board
members were Travis olefin and Fernando
Perez and John Hunter and Perry
Greenfield Jared Millman and Anthony
scope has also came in at that time
before he got on the board was our first
treasurer so can't can't leave Anthony
out of out of that picture and their
goal was to support scientific computing
projects and I think James did a great
job of talking about that one thing that
I he did he didn't mentioned a couple
things about what a fiscally sponsored
project what are some of the
requirements for that and I think one
thing he didn't mention with a code of
conduct and so it's really important
that any project that comes on board
does have a code of conduct and we make
sure that they have a policy for
inclusion and diversity that's that's in
place as well as a governance governance
model and a leadership team that is set
up that he said it you know as James
mentioned is not from one organism one
for-profit or even one university we
want to make sure it's widespread
so so that's so it's important to be
able to serve both the contributors to
the tools and also the community that
uses them so both the contributor and
the user base are very important to what
Nunn focused is doing and we're really
excited on something that kind of
affects everyone we just received a
grant from the sloan foundation for a
large sustainability project and this
will be the first project we've been
really trying to put this out there
there's a blog on then a focus website
about it we've also tried to try to get
it out through various sources talking
about this project it'll be the first
kind of first of its kind that will be
created to kind of make a toolkit for
sustainability that first of all it's
gonna be working with the Nunn focus
physically sponsored projects and after
that we're hoping it's something that
this kit can be carried on and used to
other open-source projects beyond them
focus well we have the the lead the
person that's going to be I guess
carrying this out from the Nunn focused
side will be a projects director that we
have open right now and that person will
be working with the projects working
with so the program is to be able to
create project sustainability through a
couple different ways one is to kind of
introduce projects to you know do you
need a business plan what is you know
what financially what do you need to
think about financially for your you
know the future of your project and then
also communication how are you going to
how are you communicating to the public
what your project does do you need some
help with your website do you need you
know maybe marketing might you think
about a little bit about marketing
communication to the public and then the
last step in that very important step is
to foster industry relationships so what
you know how are great corporate
relationships going to help your project
can we obviously funding is is one thing
that's important these projects are used
by a lot of companies
and those companies are being able to do
some incredible things and making lots
of money from from the tools also and
the projects are needing things there's
things that they need to make to see
happen and so how how do we foster those
relationships and bring that together
that's been a goal of enough focuses
from the beginning it's very important
right now in the open-source world
creating this kind of bridge between
corporate use and in the contributors
and you know what
I guess contributor needs in corporate
use and trying to create a bridge
between that so that will be really
important and part of that the way that
that's going to come about is through
workshops we're going to bring projects
together and actually give them training
workshops on skills brain professionals
in so the project director will work
work on that work with an advisory board
of professionals across both industry
and academia who will work with project
so that we're really excited about that
I think sustainability is a huge you
know the projects if they're if they're
not sustainable if they're not going to
continue then it's not going to do
anyone any good and so we're really
excited about that and please put the
word out there if you know someone who
would be great for that projects
Director position we're taking
applications for that right now so
well you're put you're here you're here
so you're involved and then when I gave
the talking in event it was kind of
gelled and everything came together
maybe just having that one miserable
experience made it work out and I
basically left right after my talk cuz I
was gonna speak at PI Arkansas that same
weekend so I didn't really spend more
than an hour or two at that PI data
event but I went to PI R because I had
to go to PI Arkansas
I enjoyed PI Arkansas but it's not an
event that I have been to since the
first day then the next year 2013 I
think there was a PI data event in San
Francisco and I thought I never been in
San Francisco before why don't I go to
San Francisco so I applied to speak at
that event and they kept I think there
was something about my talk title of
something that they kept getting wrong
on the schedule and I had to keep
emailing Lia about so I had a lot of
conversation back and forth Lia like can
you fix this on the schedule online but
I didn't really know and I realized
here's the thing whatever you're dealing
with large organization always be nice
to the people in operational and
administrative roles because other
people who really make things happen so
I thought I got to be really nice to
Leah silence because I can tell she's a
big shot but otherwise that no clue who
she was then I spoke again at
Boston because I live in New York and
it's not that far to go and I never been
to Boston before either and then come
hide it in New York I thought why don't
I get a little bit involved I live in
New York we have a meetup group in New
York you know it's gonna be a nice event
I'll help get some of my friends
involved get some free tickets for some
people you know give a talk myself and I
think that was a very first pilot event
that I volunteered with and of course
when you volunteer an event like this
there's always a million things to do
there's always you know one thing that's
oh this speaker needs to be in this room
instead or we need to find this speaker
the video adapters not working there's
always something to do come the next
year we had scheduled PI data London and
we had six weeks to put that together
and in a panic I said okay I'll help out
and I don't know how we made that event
happen but we made that haven't happen
and that was when I think I really first
started volunteering with them focus
because there's a pide event and it was
a lot of fun because it was a game of
who do I know who's near London who can
be emailed on a short notice to come
speak and you know people cancel for the
event at the last minute who can fill in
the event space was actually fairly
small one speaker had to had come like
from the ER to give their talk and I
went right back it was deadly sick nose
all sorts of issues there was a lot of
fun and so it kind of cascaded like that
cuz I thought if I want to go on some
vacations but I don't I'm a computer
programmer so I don't really like going
outside why don't I just go to places
for PI data conferences because I can
tell people I've been there I can tell
people I've been to London but I don't
really have to do that messy stuff like
I don't of seeing sites and dealing with
human beings I can sit in an
air-conditioned room all day and play
off my computer so I started start
attending more Pi Day events and helping
out and helped me out more and more and
more but it wasn't like at some point
somebody came to me and said oh you're
so amazing you know you need to come
help you're such an amazing person it's
just I helped out a little bit here I
helped out a little bit there and then
it just kind of snowballed and I think
that while that that is something that
we continuously see for the volunteers
that we have at our various events the
volunteers with um focus oftentimes it's
somebody who just you know they
or they were around and they wanted to
do one thing and then they got really
excited and really engaged they don't do
more and more and more and more and it's
Noble the key to that though is you
don't have to attend 25/8 events to help
out with the pie date of it you don't
have to attend 20 Pilate events to be on
stage talking to people that don't focus
you just have to be willing to do it and
you can start at any level at any size
anything that you want to do one thing
that I would really really like them
focus to do is to put together people
who can talk about numb focus at
different events in different places
because Lea's based in Texas I'm based
in New York clearly if there's an event
in San Francisco two weeks from now
neither of us will be able to attend we
would love if people would be interested
in saying I'd like to learn a little bit
about the mission of them focus and you
know get some talking points and go and
help run a booth and give out stickers
and tell people about it and tell people
what we want to do and that's really the
core of how I'm focus is supposed to
operate you know at a booth we're not
marketers we're not supposed to be there
what some fancy booth get we're supposed
to be just representatives of a broad
community that's one thing that I would
really really love to see some
volunteers especially people in San
Francisco we're willing to do if you'd
like to go to an event I'll get you a
free ticket to the event go and sit at a
booth tell people about an unfocused
help you out PI to help you about the
projects tell people about your own
personal experience using the projects
you'll have people come up to the booth
and they'll be like I've been using math
MATLAB for the last ten years
what's this Jupiter thing what's this
numpy thing you'll say oh my goodness
this is the most amazing thing ever you
gotta get on it what's this
you know I'm an I'm an AR programmer but
R is not really a great language you say
well have you looked at Julia what's
Julia you show them some demo really
changes that really changes their
perspective of us we want to find people
who can fill that role and it's not it's
not a lot doesn't require a lot just
requires the desire to you know attend
an event consider two booths and tell
people about the projects and help
support a community so that's my pitch
for all of you and I can tell you quite
quite literally those or Leah Kent Leah
can correct me because leah is the
executive director and she's the one who
actually has the authority
these things but am i understanding that
is something that we really do need
because there are a lot of events
happening on the west coast that we'd
love for an unfocused to be a part of
but we physically can't be a part of it
because they're it's hard for us to mate
and and some people who are volunteers
at this event actually served exactly
that role at the data data science
summit a couple weeks back they helped
run a booth because it was the same week
a side pie and we had to be inside by
they helped run a booth we got them into
that event they got to see some nice
talks they got to tell people about
their own experience they got to tell
people about and um focus that's all it
took so now who's interested in helping
out with something even fewer people
that's great that's great so I think
that's all the content that I have I
have prepared for this if you have any
questions I'd love to answer them
otherwise thank you very much it's been
a pleasure being able to present this
information for you and hopefully we'll
be able to do more of these kind of
sessions at future events thank you so
much